Robin got engaged to his girlfriend
April love Gary on Christmas Eve and
they're expecting yes we love love so
we're spreading a little more of that
congratulation Allah also part of this
crazy new competition show that I am
completely here for and that it's
already a huge hit outside of the US if
called the mask singer Ryan Reynolds did
a version of it I saw it it was because
it was viral and then two days later my
manager called me and said so Fox is
doing this show called the masked singer
so I just saw a Ryan Reynolds thing so I
actually had it in oh that's good yeah
so it made sense to me right away a
Deadpool star singing as a unicorn was
all it took for Robin Thicke to sign on
as a panelist standing next to Robin
Jenny McCarthy
she gave us a backstage tour so 12
celebrities are brave enough to get on
the stage and dress up in different
costumes like their alter ego and
perform in front of you guys America
where we dwindle them down each week
becoming D mask until we get down to
just one and they win ultimate prize ken
Jeong and former Pussycat Doll singer
Nicole Scherzinger round out the panel
trying to figure out who's behind the
mask
I feel like I know that voice two words
to describe it
bonkers they asked me and I said
absolutely not as well on that I'm now
sad because I love to sing so much now
what I've loved to have tricked you guys
I know I would have loved it she was she
does the most amazing Britney Spears
impersonation with it it is unbelievable
[Music]
I think my new Britney is just not even
saying any syllable destination TV I'm
telling you you're ready
[Music]